we'll start with a new segment this week
boys will clown my hound oh [ __ ]
first one sit in this is dozer this is
dozer now what is clown my hound Derek
can you give us tell us what it is
because these are fan women in the dark
brother oh no problems are fans sitting
in their animals all kinds of animals
that they own for you guys that clown
them and rip them up man
well apparently they still homeboy sent
in a goddamn panther and was roasting
this dozer now one thing I do know I
don't know a lot on this earth I know
two rivers we've been over that yeah
still one more than you here's the thing
though I dunno pups is that a kink or so
they didn't say what it is that ain't a
that might be a pity cane corso I
believe is a Bellator fighter isn't it
it might be funny if it isn't it
probably is gonna be next week there's a
lot of I feel like is that a dog you're
talking about
that's a dog yeah I can Corso Italian
king course of that but it looks like
two different dogs that's the same dog
on the left oh the same dog yeah I don't
know that's a [ __ ] pitbull bro first
of all can we talk about the dog on the
right okay so same dog the same dog oh
sure it is
I don't believe it at all tell me it is
then and then say you don't believe it
well you just told me it is why would
you believe him that's a good point I'm
speaking truth dude Cantus believe
people if they say somebody's insane
you're right keep jacking off to
snapchat you want the truth you're
turning into CNN - [ __ ] in CNN insane
dude look into it that thing is
definitely answer actually
wanna look into it bro what did he see
what happened to the pup on the road
yeah he's a year-and-a-half he's rescued
from an abandoned house and the owner
accidentally broke his leg while playing
with him oh I don't know what that
that's like when you meet a girl she has
bruises on your [ __ ] foot down the
stairs yeah I was juggling with have
something real heavy yet right that's
insane you got domestic abusers oh yeah
now let's but first of all how do we
know the one on the right I mean that
thing looks like it's hitchhiking is
that a tail is that a wiener it is a
huge is that a giant dick also where's
the dice the dog in Iraq where is that
zoom LD that ain't America baby is
unless it's area 51 could be area 51
brah this is like it this looks like a
UH like a Heinz 57 in an area 51 you
know yeah I'll tell you right now that
boys hey is that a street you'll be my
rib behinds 57 what's that that's ass
all saying it will be ketchup brown yeah
but what's that called of what is it
called when they mix a dog it's like a
mixed uh-huh mutt a mutt that ain't no
mutt that thing pure
broke that thing looks like a panther
dude that's an Iraqi Panther
it's an Iraqi Panther that's what they
use out there to defend their land it
looks like a lynx [ __ ] a safety cone
dude the animal broke for those of you
who are just listening the animal has it
one of its entire legs all the way to
the head in a orange cast broke bright
orange cast oh I know this is one of
those off-white pitbulls
[Laughter]
yeah this thing is mixed man this thing
from Seattle because well I think with
my rack bro have that Brown [ __ ] dirt
bro obviously Tigger has been [ __ ]
outside of his animal both in two months
this thing is gonna be like oh can we do
a tiger voice you kinda look like Tigger
little will you do it there I don't
remember how to forget Tigger yeah and
everybody the first one a try taker is
always so brave well what no that's not
it Yegor
so what play taker and then let's see as
the best ticket fast forward to that
goddamn stupid Tiger come on let's go
let's go that's pretty good come on
let's go yeah get to his catchphrase
only ever damn catchphrase no a
catchphrase that's good Oh
Tigger is an old man that's it where's
my tail oh my god that's your guy yeah
the depressed one yeah dude if we're
characters who I'm Tigger you're that
stupid donkey i me or but he or I'll say
this badass dude hammers his tail into
his [ __ ] ass every day do the real
mail yeah he does here's the thing not
the DJ I polish [ __ ]
heeey dude he's so depressed he's a
medication
yeah but they sometimes they don't show
him where he's on vacation and he's
having a [ __ ] blast that makes sense
I just like how this dog on the left
that ain't don't don't say this pretty
sure dog on the left the thing on the
right to legal first of all the one on
the left
uh what is it [ __ ] it looks like it
got into an argument at a stereo shop or
something why doesn't have that finger
on its face they would an idiot it keeps
biting this cast off apparently oh
really so they give him a cone of shame
that ain't even the same dog I don't get
to [ __ ] on my face any other facts on
this thing you cone in the front cone in
the back this either either as a safety
cone or its limb or it has a what is
that a bike car yeah pick one dude
either wear the cone you really got down
this thing is doing research for
definitely for Sam Tripoli and Eddie
Bravo looks like he's trying to get a
frequency on the left our seven safety
hunter right here this thing looks like
it's trying to [ __ ] it and pick up AM
radio well let's at once they just
signed the petition at [ __ ] rush area
51 on the left yeah man this thing with
that it looks like the horse grant of
animals about to keep its act together
but yeah man obviously the [ __ ]
there's no way this little bot out here
on the right [ __ ] gargoyle on the
right is the same as that [ __ ] the
cone baby on the level where'd they get
the cast work hey but also do better
honey dunk is do better around the same
pub bro this thing so this thing is hurt
but still trying to [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying when you getting that
beautiful ass orange cast he'll still
protect the land house easy I wasn't
gonna bother at the land bro you know
many other animals are gonna be able to
see him with that dude right orange cast
that's a front though you think you're
gonna make it on there they break sound
rip your dick oh I could see that so
it's like a bait in a bait and switch
yeah I say that what else we got D Wow
what's the animal's name did it have a
name dozer I don't think the biggest gay
dude at a bad now
what do you know about all that Brendon
now bathhouses know guys named dozer
dude that's a great name where you have
three in your [ __ ] phone
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]